cam newton with the indecipherable
instagram post i can't make out what is
all i see is something has been
unacceptable
and
want to be a part of the
of the solution i still don't get the
whole
alternative font with all the little
squiggly lines but uh that is hard to
read i i
yeah uh
he he had been
not ambivalent but evasive when asked
not that long ago about whether he wants
to be with the patriots in 2021 and the
reaction from a lot of patriots fans was
it doesn't matter they're not gonna want
him i mean that's the threshold question
based on the things that went wrong this
year for cam newton and the patriots is
there enough there that was good chris
in your estimation to make the patriots
want to
have cam newton in year two of the
system with the hope that second year
will be better or do they look somewhere
else for a quarterback i don't think
it's as cut and dry as just like hey the
offense hasn't looked good we're six and
eight and we're not gonna we're gonna
find another quarterback next year i
don't i i don't get that sense you know
i think you know one thing first off i
think there's a legitimate like real
respect and love for cam newton in the
new england building for the way he's
handled himself the leadership he has
shown on a daily basis i think that
there's some real genuine respect there
and what he's done for the football team
in that manner you know not easy to take
over for tom brady and deal with what
he's dealing i think also in new england
they're a very realistic group in my you
know history of knowing some of those
guys and working there they're not going
to think you know expect unrealistic
things when they know
realistically it's hard to accept or get
those results with some of the players
and team you know the team the way it's
built this year so i don't think they're
gonna like hold him to unreal
expectations of what they expected i
think they realize there's issues on
their football team at the wide receiver
position and all that so i still think
there's a chance he comes back and as
far as new england's concerned i don't
know you know the biggest thing is going
to be how comfortable do they feel with
his knowledge of the offense i think
that's really to me going to be the big
question do they feel like okay year two
now we've got the team organized around
them a little bit can we pile on all the
stuff that we like to pile on mentally
with all the formations and rules they
have in that offense which i've told you
before is as complex as it gets in
football
that to me is going to be you know the
big question going forward about whether
he's there or not
i also wonder and they're never going to
admit to this because they don't admit
to anything because they don't say
anything
are they exasperated with him do they
look back at where things went wrong and
say the moment he tested positive for
covet 19 is the moment this season
started to go off the rails and we had
been hammering into these guys every day
every day every day about what they need
to do to avoid it and he didn't listen
to us and we're not happy about that and
we're not sure that we want to continue
the relationship because we're not
thrilled about the fact that we
we emphasized how important this is and
he didn't listen to us so if we can't
listen to him on something that
important can we really trust him to be
the guy
next year and into the future it's a
tough decision too and you have all this
other heavy lifting that needs to be
done to improve the team no doubt are
you better off grooming a young guy
who's going to begin to come into the
front end of his prime as they address
these other issues because chris i look
at this and i say look at the bills look
at the dolphins don't look at the jets
and uh
they're going to be
in a tough spot new england yeah for a
couple of years minimum this isn't a
quick fix well look i i don't think this
is horrible or you know this is new
england we know they're an incredible
salary cap position next year i mean
it's the best in football so they're
going to be able to support they'll
spend it yeah if they'll spend it you're
right but we got the offensive line
settled we know that secondary still got
a lot of good pieces there
you know the big thing is going to be
about wide receiver weapons that has to
improve stefan gilmore is getting
towards the end of his contract there i
got to look that up there's a good
chance he's not there one more year
right one more year okay but the other
so wide receivers and then defense
alignment that's their biggest issue i
mean that that's another thing you know
new england for years and years has been
great because they always have a lot of
big people that might not be famous or
you know somewhat no names but they can
dominate you know bigger offensive lines
or not dominate but not be dominated and
they don't have that this year so that's
to me where it's going to start but
you're right mike i mean i'll throw this
out there the kova 19 was definitely the
downfall that's where it all started not
that it was like pretty but to that
point they were playing defense and he
was running the ball and making some
nice throws here and there and they were
winning football games but he got cover
19 they lose to the chiefs you know they
kind of outplay the denver broncos and
make some bad mistakes and lose that
football game and that's where it
funneled out of control
i
don't think new england will blame him
for covid especially with the fact that
from everything we hear it was
he was working out with the trainer and
trying to be better at football and be
better in that stuff so i don't think
new england's gonna hold it over him as
compared to like maybe if he was like
man he was you know at the club or at
the bar or hanging at some restaurant
like you know carelessly that they might
have been like i don't know if we can
trust this guy but like the fact that
you hear it was like a workout session
and all that i don't think they're gonna
hold that against them why do you need
to work out on your own though when you
have that facility that's pristine
that's subject to all the problems that
makes no sense i know so many players do
it well so many players do it and you
know at a lot of the times of course
with nfl football teams you know it's a
lot of players on a football team the
strength and conditioning coach has to
set out workouts that kind of work for
everybody a little bit and
with some of these players in the nfl as
much money as they're making and things
like that sometimes they just want
something more specific to what they
want to do what they need to improve and
there's a lot of people that do that i
mean tom brady did it when he was up
there too it's just it's part of the new
world of football let me ask you this
mike
do you think
the other thing that like possibility
maybe knowing new england maybe they
keep cam newton
i don't know what their thought is with
jared siddom maybe they draft a
quarterback in the second or third round
and maybe they just have him sit behind
cam newton for another year or so and
develop them i mean i would think that's
a possibility that's on the table as
well
i think that makes sense the question is
what do they feel about the guys who are
going to be available
what do we trust though about
the we don't trust the evaluation of
receivers right for as great as the
steelers are organizationally and we
have to give gm kevin colbert the credit
there because he's the guy who's who's
got the title
they do such a good job the patriots do
such a bad job and it's bill belichick
the gm
and his failings making it harder on
bill belichick the head coach and that's
been a lingering issue but without tom
brady without a quarterback who can play
at a really high level and with the
losses piling up it's going to become
more and more pronounced and the other
question too is how long will the fans
tolerate this yeah they fill up that
stadium they're spoiled you've said it
before they take for granted the playoff
birth if they're just a middle of the
pack team next year and the dolphins are
coming to town and pushing them around
and the bills are coming to town and
lighting them up on the scoreboard how
long will the fans tolerate it and how
do you fix it and at what point
does the bill belichick routine begin to
wear out in new england it's one thing
to put up with him yeah he's delivering
championships if he's not delivering
championships that routine is going to
get old very quickly and speaking of an
old routine that we know and love here's
a little belichick from yesterday when
he was on weei
every week he asked me something's
changed
and i told him i've already changed
though because you guys have been
eliminated right so maybe you look at
stidhum the last two weeks
okay um no because i'm just saying
because
i i do wonder what that fine line what
how do you balance it right i mean it's
i don't know if it's just because we're
watching cam newton play
and i think myself and people that watch
it there's a struggle with him moving
the football downfield throwing the
football and we're just looking at i
don't know if it's stidham's not showing
what he needs in practice once you're
eliminated to give him a couple games
just to see what he looks like in a game
as a starter
[Music]
yeah great point though
my goodness
uh
you know again whatever they pay for
bill belichick to do that on one hand
it's not enough and on the other hand
there's never an amount that's enough to
justify it but there's not enough from
the radio stations perspective because
that is gold and you know how hard it is
to intentionally fall silent on a phone
call like that i'm surprised they didn't
just assume the call dropped that's what
i would have thought hello is he there
did he drop the phone like he was
digging through the drawer like he was
like oh wait i gotta write some notes to
myself about practice later today hold
on a second oh that's right i want to
interview you know i i i just don't
think
you know they're into entertaining those
questions i don't think they probably
know exactly what they want to do in the
off season and i don't think in case
they bring cam newton back or have that
in their visions that they want to start
that quarterback controversy talk one
thing i know just with my time with josh
mcdaniels in denver and going in new
england the patriots are about framing
their team and they believe in getting
that general of the ship aka tom brady
or whatever and now we're going to
formulate our team and this is our
lifeline of our team here this year and
they don't want that you know
quarterback conversation i think they
view that as you know you know a bad
thing it's something that brings them
down i just feel that that's why he's
not going to answer those questions i
don't think and start that you know
hoopla around that
it's also a contractual challenge with
cam newton he's signed only for this
year they're not going to use the
franchise tag on them we have not seen
enough to justify 26 27 million for next
year so they're going to have to let him
go out into the world and run the risk
of someone else signing him if they do
want him back unless they can get
something done before free agency begins
in march
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports